[Music]
so
hello everyone i would like to thank you
for joining me today
on the stream it's really annoying that
whenever i tab out of
full guys oh it uh
immediately mutes the game it's like i
wish that you could just have that those
bangs
well yeah back to back you know what i'm
saying you know what i'm saying uh let
me jump in and discord
hello steve
oh webcam hey i'm doing it
hey hey what's up you did the thing yo i
did
the thing i like the name of the place
by the way
that's on brand for you i just made it
right now
because i was like this is the first
time that i've been like hello four
people would you like to stream
um and usually i use someone else's
server i make a temporary one i was like
like it let's just let's just do it it's
really uh
serendipitous that you sent that message
because the thing that you sent me
i was actually hanging out in said place
and thinking oh i wonder
and then like i didn't want to be the
guy that does that to you like hey
surprise
but you thought the same thing yeah
uh let me leave a link in chat to
everyone this is steven spawn
he's a cool guy it's steve
in spawn correct
[Music]
i'm not helping you promote me that's
very humble of me fam
good job here we go here's steve ass
what's up
[Laughter]
jesus dude look at your [ __ ] your uh
oh my god yeah yeah yeah i'm a mecca
kitty
holy [ __ ] i don't know right
okay let me hang on let me invite you to
you does party
kitty i'm against micro transactions uh
strongly against i don't do it
oh well i did do it the other day to buy
a dog and sea of thieves so i'm breaking
my rules one step at a time but you
can't
you can't stand like on a glacier and
then be like just kidding
this one time i know i'm conflicted i'm
conflicted okay it's fine no no you
you need five pounds how many crowns do
you got i have two currently
oh yeah well no i'm not proud of it
well i'll teach you okay
how many do you have uh zero now because
i just not falling in the suit
but you did have at least five that
means i had five yeah
dang yeah yeah yeah well you know one
day i'll be as cool as you steve one day
uh you know what i was just talking to
my channel about this the problem with
this is you look really damn cool
but then everybody wants to mess with
you because they think you're really
good
which is false that makes sense you get
grabbed a lot i understand
i do yep i gotta go just waiting for you
yeah
so i'm sorry about that
are you really though like on a scale of
one to ten actually you know what i'm
glad you asked i personally am not sorry
um especially because i am not a grabber
in this game i don't do grabs
i'm i'm polite so i will shame them
good yeah you do yeah and like call them
out like just call them just call them
out on twitter be like this guy
sucks if i knew any people okay actually
i do have one personal friend who's
grabby
i do have one personality's grabby my
chat is already talking about chris
evans penis
and i would just like to say it's still
a leak of a private photo i feel like
we're taking it less seriously because
it's a man
i feel like this is still something that
is extremely invasive
and that we should not be being like lol
dudes dick you know because that sucks
um more important news speaking of
things that are fire
uh i am currently trying to raise money
for the american red cross
um in order to
have relief for the uh
it fires so donate if you like we're
doing that today
that's the plan i already raised
seventeen thousand dollars which is
[ __ ] incredible
um my goal was two thousand five hundred
so we're smashing it
okay well yeah you can't you can't make
a transition like
i'm actually pretty proud of that
transition because i technically
yeah still recovering from it oh yeah
yeah i mean i don't know that he was
hacked whatever just
it's not necessarily chris evans penis
it could be anyone's really from the
context of the thing i'm just saying
i want to point out that when this hour
is examining the evidence
i may have well i found it by accident
because if people's nudes leaks i refuse
to look for them
right so like if i had heard his nudes
leaked i would have been like i'm not
gonna look this up because it's really
[ __ ] up again
i feel like we're not taking this one as
seriously because it's a dude
like if this or a woman would be like
don't look at it but we're like yeah
chris evans is dick you're like come on
man
that's not that's not fair that's sexist
towards men you know
um but i did see his name was trending
and that's how i saw it is that andy is
that andy the andy show up it is
they showed up g'day mate good day hello
steven hello alana how's it going we
just started
um so we're just gonna we're just gonna
wait for you to finish your round
oh gary's also here hello welcome yes
um i don't know if i have both of you on
my steam friendly i think i added you
recently gary but we can
figure it out oh gosh i added andy but i
don't think i have you gary
cool have fun you guys yeah happy to be
a part of it happy to be here
oh this is on you alana it is it's
absolutely
oh that's why i was gonna say it was on
twitch
exclusivity is stupid and i don't
support it alana is definitely
a friend of mine i don't think steve is
so i need to add him
wow
not a friend at all oh [ __ ] i'm playing
terribly what am i even
it's like i'm not even paying attention
well that's what's going on
to be fair steve if we're not friends
it's because it's either you either you
either never sent me a friend invite or
you never accepted mine so this is on
you
or it's just you have like very varying
political views and it's not gonna work
out between you what the [ __ ] am i doing
alana what's wrong with you okay at
least steve's right here too
i feel good about that i am god you look
so cool and i [ __ ] it up as well
this is like the worst i've ever played
okay no buddy
i don't even deserve to qualify i'm not
even watching but just based on the
sounds it sounds like me and gary won't
have to wait around very long
no you're gonna be just fine well i
don't know it sounds like she's
struggling right now i qualified
yeah but you haven't seen steve's
[ __ ] epic suit that he had to spend
five crowns
that's true is it the space cat suit
yeah
yeah oh my god stephen i've been getting
destroyed by all sorts of space cat
people
nightmare like they have been coming
after me dude i was just saying before
like the problem with space cats is
everybody's hassling them right now so
if you're wearing it it's like a target
it is you're the only you're the only
space cat among us right now steve
oh thank you oh the name is not a
compliment
i just pointed out a fact i don't know
why you took it as a compliment
steve i just put my style back in the
discord so when you're ready you can
add me beautiful and then we'll be all
get all good together are you
are you too ready because i can just go
in but i honestly don't care no
oh well i i also made it so oh did you
yeah i didn't deserve it but i did make
it sounding great mm-hmm
it's a yeah time um
yeah everyone i am currently streaming
on youtube and twitch this stream is to
uh raise money for the american red
cross for the fire relief efforts
um probably stream for a couple hours
try to get rid of those fires they're
real
bad how are you doing up in uh san
francisco
uh i mean you saw what though that what
that sky was like i mean yeah
as bad as it looked on tv it was ten
times as surreal
in reality is everyone saying cameras
just don't pick it up
yeah and you actually have to like color
correct the image to get it to look like
what your eyes is yeah my phone my phone
kept trying to white balance it
yeah that happened in my apartment the
other day when it was orange so i just
ended up using my dslr because my phone
literally wouldn't take a photo of it
it's like this is white now
it wasn't the orange that was weird it
was the if that smoke layer diffused so
much sunlight that it was effectively
night in the middle
yeah every light in the house on it at
noon [ __ ] nuts
jesus christ um yeah i've definitely
uh i tried to do cardio today and i
didn't qualify on that one
um couldn't because my asthma is just so
bad when it's
this thick of smoke but otherwise it's
just like you just constantly feel like
you have something in your chest
like it's just yeah you just wake up and
you're like
because there's so much [ __ ] right
now is so bad my wife just bought like
an industrial
strength air purifier and the air
quality index
uh tells us that currently if you're
outside during the day today it's the
equivalent of smoking artifact
cigarettes
jesus yeah i think it said that
yesterday at least uh san francisco had
the worst quality
of air in the entire world apparently
today is vancouver
really yeah but it definitely was the
bay area like we always get it
bad this time of year because of the
final fire season
i'm actually just talking about that to
a friend of mine uh
just studying to be a meteorologist and
i was like can you explain the
scientific process like when there's
that much gluten in here how does it
really get dissipated they were like it
really doesn't until it runs into more
trees i'm like well we're cutting those
down so
that's great fantastic yep
really makes you think that's really
what we'll be doing to that earth
there you are stephen i i got eliminated
by the way so you guys
can invite you to the squad alana and
then invite
are you let me see here wait what oh
well we'll wait steve's still going
we'll wait till steve finishes i know so
i'll get you
well you've got the invite i see what
you're saying i see what you're saying
yeah i feel you
and then and then uh it's okay that's
you
four 406 six volume no so those nice
nice nice um are you in
vancouver i've seen some photos of
vancouver it doesn't look as bad as i
feel like la's look
but uh it's for 420 [ __ ] crushed
oh did you get out steve no
i'm spelling i mean it's a winner what's
your stream get that crown
how are you doing with the crowns not
good gary i prefer not to talk about it
what if we didn't discuss it do you do
you do you have
some no so here's the thing
i'm not a competitive person at all so i
feel like
generally when i get to the final rounds
i a panic a little bit because i don't
know what to do and then inevitably [ __ ]
up
or b that's very normal yeah true um i'm
generally trying to help my friends win
because i'm a weird kind of not
competitive that my friends winning
makes me very happy but i
don't care so much about it um but i'm
holding out folks it's
great to be playing in a squad because
you know we very much believe in the
concept of team crowns around here
we do okay i have some friends who are
against it
i'm all for that merely against it but
that's fine that's cool
yeah i'm just saying when i turned into
gary's stream at the start of the
evening he was at seventeen now he's
like
hello everyone yeah three crowns tonight
oh wow gary damn okay
yeah now one of them terrible yesterday
today's better
one of them might have no asterisk candy
[Music]
that goddamn clip every everybody in my
chat saying the andy hilton i've been on
gary's side the whole time and now i'm
just like i don't know it could be an
asterisk man
it's me i feel like my presence makes
you evil andy that's what i sense
it was one of those desync issues where
on gary's
screen the other guy looked like he had
two feet to go to hit the crown
and gary got there first and then
okay check out this clip that i just put
in the discord
okay it's so good you only need to watch
like the first few seconds of it it's
the very last part of it and you tell me
what you think
you put a clip in the discord you say
uh oh no you know i put it in the wrong
one hold on
i'm like i don't know if you did
okay gary that is some [ __ ] no oh
daddy yeah [ __ ] kidding me thank you
very much
yeah no that's that's kind of insane
yeah yeah i don't know i mean you know
the thing is though here on that guy's
screen maybe you were two feet away from
it that's
i know i'm just trying to throw out also
take it up with that guy
steve are you in the last round i i am
oh gleeger says he stole it from a
nine-year-old
clicker gary
my favorite is uh i don't know if you
guys know this andy why don't you bet
him
steve always has to have something on
his lap because if he doesn't his cat
will jump on him
it's very good okay let me send you an
invite to
a new group dude
i still need stephen to accept my uh to
send me a friend request well i
added him to the group so it shouldn't
matter i am but i still want to be his
friend though
well thank you justin and albatros
stephen i want like a lasting friend uh
we'd love some rain kevin that'd be
amazing
i mean this is project soul i've asked
to be a guest and podcast
i have asked just accept it
i'm not someone you can just play four
guys with one night and then like not
call again
you know yeah a piece of meat stephen
i think you're a whole snack buddy
should annie and i leave or should we oh
no
we need to leave you guys to it
[Laughter]
oh jeez the wit
um all right i'm good we just go ahead
and play i don't need to wait for
steven's friend request
he obviously doesn't want to do it are
you literally clicking on your name
are you the tomato right now gary i am
the tomato
that's very cute i love it i love the i
love the little uh the little shorts
yeah i'm a spaceman but i gave myself
the um the kind of shorts that i wear
literally constantly right now because
my
idea was that i'm an astronaut who's
retired
so it's like a deadbeat dad but still
was an astronaut
or you're an [ __ ] like on a zoom call
or like just yeah
they can't do it yeah i like that you
put thought into your backstory
yeah i like really like to roleplay so
i just got into my character
okay there is the stephen the covenant
you guys did it you made it work
friend requests i'm not even gonna okay
i'm gonna admit it just because i like
making fun of myself i kept searching
alana's friend list for gary and it
wouldn't come up
like damn it why is this not working
okay i figured it out got it
well gary we are friends ready uh yes
yeah um
do i need to do this oh yeah y'all can
squat up oh yeah
and andy needs andy needs to invite
steve is that true
engage xv they said do you ever think
about how squirrels are herbivores until
they get their first taste of human
blood
the thing is i'm worried that gary may
not want to invite stephen
what's your channel name again can you
guys just stop beefing jesus boys is so
dramatic again
just accept that i accepted and so so
are there anything being mean to you
uh that's definitely now the three of us
are squad streaming
i've been saying this since day one gary
won that crown the whole way
have you yeah i don't know if that's
true felicia day
in the chat oh i love felicia there's
something about not having a spot for
her i mean i feel like if you've shown
up a bit earlier
this is like a high-class restaurant you
can't just show up and expect you know
me to have the best table for you
i mean i am more than happy to bail out
for felicia she's pretty awesome
no no one's asking
you'll be the first person
uh tonight we're playing with uh the
wonderful and talented alana pierce
uh kind of funny is andy cortez no
no i and the incredible uh stephen spawn
ryan reynolds best friend
no adjectives in front of my name that's
crazy no definitely not
he didn't even say it was a little funny
he said we said you were good no there's
no descriptor
[Music]
he said kind of funny that's funny he
was calling you kind of funny
unrelated to the brand like this guy's a
really good basketball player nothing
like that
are you allowed i'm really good at
basketball
uh are you
i'm really good basketball okay any any
are you though i don't
you know i'm just not i've only i've
only ever seen them dunk chicken wings
so i can't
i can't talk to her i mean you could be
right into action here i love a hit
parade i love a hit parade i do i do
really want to play again with felicia
at some point i'm desperate to get her a
crown i think it's really starting to
wear on her that she doesn't have one
yet
well yeah yeah the whole uh if you go to
bed at night just sort of wondering what
could have been
yeah no chat we're not calling it alana
steve gary and that guy
no you should rename the stream
usually if i stream with you andy i i
don't know which of your
monikers to call you because there's
andy cortez which is what i generally go
with but then there's also maximum
cortez but then i also really like nitro
rifle
yeah i like the whole nitro rifle i do
too it's really bad now oh my gosh
mosh pit uh so i never know which one to
choose you know
i feel like andy cortez is always yeah
i've been wanting to like if i could
all my social handles would be andy
cortez are they not all no i mean like
you know everything's maximum cortez but
just like
because andy cortez is taken by a dude
who tweeted once in 2010
um i do own a lana pierce on everything
except youtube because someone made a
fake account where they would
just uh zoom in on my boobs and upload
videos
so that account was removed but it means
that i am not allowed to
retake that account um so i could have
alana ps on everything except youtube
because of that
accusing you of being like a booby
streamer or something no this is way
before like that was even a thing people
were accused of yeah it was just someone
who wanted to look at my boobs i guess
a guy's always like okay clipping out
parts of me just like shooting
basketballs
and it's like enough like i can't i'm
not just the basketball player you know
you are an incredibly good one but
you're more than that so
yeah i hate being relegated to just that
yeah but like
charlotte is recognizable but difficult
to spell but then alana pierce is also
difficult to spell because alana and
pierce have a million different
ways to spell things so it doesn't help
anyway what's the [ __ ] thing a lot of
people
go is your favorite level uh my favorite
level a lot of people call me
middle guy middle guy became a thing
because
when we did the e3 sort of watch along
uh we were put on the twitch front page
and we had
like so many viewers that didn't even
know who we were watching us and they
kept calling me middle guys so i just
became a middle guard
that was hilarious the middle guy thing
were you just in i assume you were just
sitting in the middle
yeah that's all it was you'd be like oh
middle guy's funny little guy needs to
shut up
that's just all it was good stuff
i guess i get blonde chick for that kind
of stuff but you know it's just
a lot of us not as many middle guys out
there you know silver
it is but i think it confuses people
it's an illusion
so you're the lighting blonde whatever i
don't know
it's fine how about you gary i'm sure
you get like star wars guy
oh i i must suck um
no no one's ever called me star wars guy
um no you know i wouldn't identify you
as star wars guy even though
you wrote rogue one i feel like
yeah animal talking guy works i'm a man
for all seasons
you can't define me that easily i'm
complicated
i've always only one thing magazine
multifaceted yeah pc magazine
quadruple threat x cos guy
you know and then there's steve
the guy with no accolades to his name
frankly the least interesting of all of
us
you're verified on twitter that's all
that matters dude all right that's sir
yeah
oh at least twitter so at least twitter
saw my soul checked
you get that twitter you get that
twitter check mark you start getting
those 20k
checks in the mail every month it's
great oh man i love that they came in to
say garbage on twitter it's amazing
me on the other hand still uh still
waiting oh you're not terrified
i love that one day where all the
verifieds couldn't tweet
and i just went online and i was like
you know what greg miller [ __ ] tired
of the guy
[Laughter]
i never want to play i was working all
day so i didn't see any of it and then
when i came back and looked at twitter i
was like what [ __ ] madness is going
on here that i missed and then looking
into how that actually happened is
fascinating like it was really bizarre
what a breeze
um they they they tricked twitter
employees into giving up their personal
information right that they used for
the login insane like a social engineer
they hacked twitter not hacked those
accounts it's absolutely right they
hacked the employees
yeah it's just crazy oh [ __ ] good grab
i mean what can you do versus social
engineering oh i almost stole your tail
steve
isn't that
oh you're dead it's a different space
cat let's [ __ ] him up let's beat him up
let's do his lunch buddy
it's a different it's a different space
cat space get away from me
okay that's you annie i'm not gonna
touch
gary and i here hanging out not getting
any tails like that guys okay that's
good thank you very much
[ __ ] no get away from me oh
i grabbed you you son of a you son of a
gun wow okay you need to swear
you did do you word no okay sorry i got
it
this is you this right now we're in late
night andy mode right
we're saying crazy
[Music]
it again you [ __ ] me too me too me
too me too i don't think i can get it
back
no i can't i can't i can't [ __ ] man
clutch that was rough who made it
through who made it through i made it
just youtube holy [ __ ]
me and andy hello sam what's up okay i
lost tonight with like five seconds ago
that was so scary
yeah yeah and the final round of course
is anything goes but like
before the final round you've got to try
to preserve the integrity of the squad
yeah yeah we need everybody to go
through that was clutch
oh i'm so bad at this one i just get
knocked off on this we've been doing
good at this one
oh you did get knocked off that oh yeah
i like this one a lot yeah
that [ __ ] with it i'm starting to
develop a better feel for this game
how much have you played i feel like i
get the impression you've played a fair
bit
a lot an awful lot this is a lot of
people
yeah you have a whole show about it
the hacker just knows whenever they're
just running through
suddenly my player gets knocked to the
side like all right we got 25
uh someone in my chat when i got knocked
out said felicia day would have won that
like [ __ ] you're probably right wow god
dammit
two of my three crowns tonight from full
mountain all right gary
wait mate all three of them yeah all
three of them
yeah this is the best one so
give me a damn hexagon how you got yours
right steve
yep yep i can't do um hexagon i'm
[ __ ] terrible at it i need to learn a
stretch
oh my god how did i fall i like falling
i like the jumping one [ __ ] stumble
yep always jump off of that oh wow okay
gary all right i've got a friendly
friendly oh geez you did get a friendly
eat congrats that actually helped you
significantly dude
oh gary oh gary oh gary this is amazing
these
dodges are you we got a [ __ ]
professional on our hands here
you're going for number four right now
bro yep you're
if you don't miss gary gary gary gary
gary
it's gonna time nicely for me oh my god
congratulations that was a beautiful run
i mean i don't want to brag did you see
that zigzagging like yes
that was some of the most pro [ __ ] i've
ever seen the guy's insane chad
the guy's insane we've never seen that
much skill
god damn dude all right still basically
gary
if he wanted to holy [ __ ] i got a side
i'm very pleased with myself from that
that was [ __ ] nuts man
congrats you act like you've been there
before jesus christ
i'm gonna need to go back and clip that
one for myself because that that was
beautiful that was the thing of beauty
my chat said gary with the modesty
you know very good i always say it's not
mod it's not bragging when you can back
it up
yeah i think it's bad i'm just gonna say
you guys
we just got a dub if everyone donated
ten dollars then we would have
eighteen thousand dollars for fire
relief efforts right now whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
what happened we need to we need to
remake the squad yeah i got backed out
it knocked me yeah
suddenly um twitter
oh my god gary i'll be honest with you i
was hoping that you choked to that
because i was right behind you
for the win i don't think it didn't even
feel i mean i didn't even feel like
there was anyone that close behind me i
felt like it was no
no he was right behind you oh were you
really andy you're not coming up on my
online
list um i can maybe invite him hold on
let me try that how's that how's that
did that work there you go yeah
it says you're offline weird okay
i don't know on my screen it was just
nothing but gary for a day
i don't know yes thank you maybe hey
yeah
killed it light years what years even
okay i did it i am done sorry
oh astronaut oh astronaut
is that did you write me a poem just now
oh astronaut my astronaut
so that would that was our first game as
a squad right and it was a team crown
yep yeah 100 100 win rate as a squad
right now 100 we should oh my god you're
right
yeah we should absolutely stop playing
right now all right on the table
familiar
yeah just literally out of the room
uh so the person who just asked the the
link to donate
is i don't know how to describe it on
twitch
you know the area where the panels are i
don't [ __ ] twitch this house
it's just there and then in youtube it's
the first line of description so
you know trying to raise money get rid
of fire that's how it works you throw
cash at the fire and the fire goes away
oh no don't actually go to the fire and
throw money at it no no
no no no no donate to the american red
cross so they can do
no credit cards added though yes yeah
yeah yes
that gas gives you a real nice high
getting high on plastic for the record i
do not endorse this please don't sue me
do not inhale the fumes of plastic
oh man gary we got we got sandy
dominating this seesaw game
right now we got oh yeah you guys are
first and second i mean actually steve
and i are also doing pretty well back
here you know not not
gary and andy stratt but oh steve oh
no you hate to see it look at this andy
look at this this is ridiculous look at
this
yeah all right it's not all right it's
so unfair that we were at the front you
guys really did get one and two right
there nice work
nice clean work by quite a distance
um what numbers are i'm
nice nice nice nice nice nice nice i
[ __ ] hate this purple one
specifically
why you you didn't say at least four no
more nicest you needed to go with them
all right can you all help me tilt
please this [ __ ] purple son of a
[ __ ]
what are we even supposed to do here you
know oh my god if you guys stand over
this side it will tilt faster
i don't know if you know how physics
work [ __ ]
no no they don't no they do
this is really i think the level where
you get the most angry at the stupidity
of other players well i do because
seesaw is a team game but i often feel
like i'm the only one playing it as a
team game
um it's the only level i dislike there
i'm really bad at slime climb but i
don't dislike it
just bad at it oh no okay we can make
this
buddy one sucks
if you're not at the front it says angie
i i mean i guess i wouldn't know
all right gary ah [ __ ] hell
no i should dial into your character
here no of this is my fault
none of this is my fault i'm just being
wrong come on
you know come a little ass how about now
do it
okay okay i think you can make it
yes i can make it yes you're going to
come in like really unless this like
this hot dog tries to start some [ __ ] oh
he didn't yeah you're gonna yeah there
you go
okay steve did you get through i did not
because you jumped off the other side of
the platform and i thought wow
it was my fault i don't want to
subscribe to this but
um typically when we do squads if
someone doesn't qualify out of the first
round we'll
back out and start over just for the
first round
yeah oh wait so do we want to drop out
right now no no
that wasn't the first round is that the
i always forget i'm like is this the
final round now i don't know what's
happening yeah you're right
no that was the first round okay so we
should have dropped down what's this one
let's look okay let's let's start it on
the next one because it wasn't playable
yeah
yeah okay also just like the call side
if amanda would help me
so i'm sorry i didn't even realize you
were there
oh i didn't even see you i'm sorry
it's a team game right team alana oh i'm
sorry
i mean there is no i in the lana wait
nope
no i in my entire name but an l
kind of looks like one sometimes oh
that's a good point sometimes on like
uh i don't know whatever shitty websites
i used as a
remember i'm not on the squad so it's
fine alone do you consider yourself
a good gamer are you good at games it
depends what games so like
i'm very good at an action adventure i'm
good at dark souls types i was really
good at
niamh uh good at sakura souls is a good
game to be good at yeah so i'm
i'm good at a a um
basically like a melee combat focus hack
and slash or a dark souls
uh which is not that useful uh where
multiplayer is concerned
um the only like shooters i'm good at
are ones that are a little bit slower
paced because i played so much
yeah i'm gonna doom but i don't feel
like it's such a weird distinction in
that
i don't feel like doom is that fast
paced like it is
but it's you don't die as fast as you do
in call of duty
so like i'm really bad at cod because my
reaction times aren't fast enough
whereas doom i feel like i at least have
a little bit more time to think so i can
do doom i could do a third person shoot
i've played gear semi-professionally for
a little bit
um but there's plenty of games i'm
terrible at too platforming if you had
to play a game in a competitive
scenario what would you choose to play
the game that i'm the best at
would be a racing game uh project golf
and racing forza or mario kart racing
okay
sure oh okay racing games all right wow
wow come on okay here we go slang climb
it's not fun
remember the key to this level is to
mentally dominate it you gotta you gotta
be i'm
awful at slam climb don't let it hold
anything once you no longer
fear it there's nothing to fear that
checks out
i buy the logic yeah yeah the only fear
is
the fear of slime is that yeah it's
i'm just like really bad at that like
one yellow tube
oh yes standing there yeah
so the only the only trick that i
learned on that one you probably already
know this is like don't jump onto that
first log walk right onto it so yeah you
only have to jump once
i'm bad at this part too though for the
record yeah one this is because the
stupid beans getting in my way for the
rifle
that's what i'm saying anytime anyone
makes a bean joke i just
try to make a sex oh my god i hate these
beans so much
yeah oh [ __ ] see i'm
guys i already lost i'm [ __ ] terrible
it's like are you in the slime
yeah i got slimed okay i'm very bad
okay i'll cross now sometimes i wish
this game had opened voice chat actually
no that would be the worst can you
imagine the chaos
can you imagine what this would be the
most toxic game
in the business i would be the most
talking person you're like
there's no reason to do this other than
today where'd you go tomorrow did you
did you just qualify is that why i lost
you
no he's not in the beginning 1478. i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna wait here for
him to [ __ ] die he's gonna have to go
grab
right now gary i'm making a stance right
now i am not
going to go for this win i'm going after
fall guy 18. are you going to try and
try yeah
oh did he knock you off gary yeah you
successfully knocked me off
oh he's going to die no no no no he's
still there
[Laughter]
deserved sometimes i
know but i was really looking forward to
just making the rest of his life a
living hell i was going to go out would
have been funny
yeah ruin his career yeah yeah
all right
[Music]
too because um feel like top left is
right too many times in a row and my
blood pressure
and that start yelling at somebody who
accidentally bumped me and then i mean i
would i would probably
i would if this guy open voice chat i'd
be in prison right now
nine nine-year-old just starts crying
and you yell at them like oh i'm so
sorry
uh what number you end up you know be
the nine-year-old to be the most toxic i
am
46-31 4-6-3-1
andy cortes 4-6-3-1 nice
there he is guy fieri
anytime anyone has the fire pants i
think that guy fury that's a good ai
that is the most high voltage have you
ever had
anybody use that for anything or is that
just something you've got i actually did
uh just last week i had to do my ai
voice for the first time which is like
it's it's such a funny thing to do in
voice acting because they're like so you
know just
do it like a robot they can't really
give you any instruction for it and
every line reads sounds very similar
like it's hard to even vary it but uh
yeah it's one that i feel like
um there's an indie game that when like
not sure if it's going to happen that i
might be playing like
a hal type ai in that i'm super excited
about if the project ends up getting
funny to come together um
i think andy's starting to realize that
me on his football team it's not quite
as easy
way too many people on football right
now i am 100
downs for murderbot alana thank you
i will destroy your family and your
first born
child oh my god yeah that's good
thank you uh you are absolutely right
andy this is way too many [ __ ] people
what is this a mosh pit
i've never seen it with as many people i
love that they have the the peabody from
um
portal 2 as a skin now oh yeah do they
have atlas as well
yeah i think i unlocked shell but i
don't have a
trick keep the pressure on no
there's too many goalies this sucks man
yeah
they're just gonna park the bus now put
everyone behind the board yeah
hey lana did you see liverpool's opening
game today apparently it was really
amazing uh of course i did you big dummy
why are you kidding gary yeah no i
watched it live it was uh it was a hell
of a game it was a cracker
leads apparently really really gave him
again they did great yeah but it's also
like
liverpool have just been playing badly
lately like compared to how they were
playing at the start of last season
they've just been playing
kind of bad um and people been dropping
[ __ ] where they shouldn't but masala is
my favorite player
he got a hat trick today uh i [ __ ]
love him it was
beautiful we're talking about liverpool
right now
now leeds leads is great like very very
good stuff it was a good game
leads are going to make a lot of noises
i do too we do two they'll be in the top
half
oh no prize package this season
yeah it's ot i think this season is
going to be
man city liverpool chelsea united
arsenal is my guess for the top five
yeah yeah yeah are you mad at me and i
think arsenal are actually
on the upswing right now yeah they're
starting to kind of fix up
the problems the weird thing is i'm
starting to see already some like like
like the fan sentiment kind of starting
to turn against plop a little bit i'm
like really already
wait really oh i know that yeah just a
little bit because because they feel
like
he's not making not made the right um uh
moves in the close season new players
being brought in well so the reason for
that
um they did speak about that publicly is
that
liverpool is a club you know we're not
an oil money club like city
liverpool is a club that is affected by
coven so
we couldn't make purchases we don't have
money right now where all the other
clubs
uh or no not all the other clubs that's
not fair as the city's got that
city and chelsea are okay exactly i
always call them the ea of
uh formulaic dubs while i do really like
pep
i really like him uh as as a manager too
i think i've got some criticism for
talking about why they haven't spent
much in the close season and was accused
by some fans of like kind of parroting
the uh the fenway sports group like
corporate line about why they haven't
spent a lot i mean he might have to do
that but he's generally like super
genuine i really like club too
like i think he's i think he's by far my
favorite uh manager in the in the league
yeah yeah very real like i love when
people kept asking him about um
he was like what are you how do you feel
about chronovirus what should we do he
was like
look i'm a football manager yeah i know
that feels like it's important but like
ultimately football doesn't matter as
much as health i don't know why you're
asking me and not asking doctors like i
was just like dude respect like i fully
yeah very very glad to have him did you
ever did you ever see the clip when uh
liverpool was like in europe in some
european tournament like a couple of
years ago
and he got asked this question at a
press conference by this like french
journalist
who had like this really sexy voice yes
yes and he was like a very seductive
voice yeah he's like erotic maybe
yeah you say it again yeah i love him
are any of you still in oh yeah yeah
okay sandy oh andy
uh he's in the final round do you think
he muted us because we were talking
about the wrong kind of football
he's doing really well right now i can
understand why he would want to focus
right now
he is doing well you might be the he's
the furthest at the top i think of
anyone
he's the highest highest
no you can drop to this blue right here
and you're gonna be good there's ton
spoiler yeah there's a lot of real
estate down there yeah he really made
the best of that later yep
oh gosh oh i don't know why he started
running good play oh my gosh andy get a
little bit more complicated here he's
gonna like
okay okay that's all right it's all
right all right it's right right it's
all right
oh my god they're recovering he can
recover
he's got a shot here five are gone
oh i'm [ __ ] yeah this is gonna get
real spicy [ __ ]
no no no no no no
yeah he's got the dive he's got the dive
maneuver down
damn it devastating i felt i don't i
don't want to like
backseat that but i guess i'm going to i
felt like there was more there was more
real estate
the other in the other direction but
it's easy for me to say that
yeah we're not in the heat at the moment
yeah yeah once you get down there
you got to keep an eye on where people
are as well yeah yeah
yeah that's like i don't know i feel
like it's not common that you see that
many people on that bottom layer as we
did just now either
like there were too many of them in the
game i'll just drive i'll just drop down
and just take out the bottom layer so
that
that doesn't even happen yeah it happens
some people do it they'll drop to the
bottom layer and then run around like
running patterns emptying it out but
you've got to be able to pull that off
i don't think it's really a valid thing
otherwise you'd be seeing more people
doing it i don't think it's actually a
good idea
i started running in that one moment
because somebody else was encroaching on
my
land and i wanted to cut them and
quarter them off so that they wouldn't
be able to get to me but
i didn't do it fast enough so yeah the
blocks were still
there as they were running behind me as
well so that
really really [ __ ] me up if i could
have blocked them off a lot earlier i
think i would have been super good
are you playing with a keyboard or
controller with a controller
xbox elite two baby it's a good
controller i'm good controller i'm
playing with that with a hat on my head
so yeah what does the hat do steve i've
never actually asked you what you do
with the hat
that's literally an infrared sensor so
it just senses when i move my hat
in certain directions and emulates
keyboard what presses
so cool it's essentially a keyboard but
it's a hat
so so so cool that's insane that's
awesome
it only gets hard when either you have
to sneeze and you accidentally shoot
your friend
and once in a while i really do get the
blame chat because they'll say something
funny i'll look over you'll laugh
turn my head
oh very good jesus
okay how do you jump is that mouse
uh down down that's around the cliff you
can see me like
uh using my jaw
lucky there it's very cool don't touch
me
don't touch me egg damn i'm a cat
that's just alone hey don't touch it
don't touch me
you get out of here
you see that alana is smart enough to
not go mid also yeah it's [ __ ] stupid
also you gotta go left because people
from mid get eaten to right
so that's why we're over here tomorrow
that's why we're out here we're doing
the thing
i go because i'm left handed and i just
naturally favor the left when i'm
oh yeah i'm uh i'm left footed but right
handed
oh that's weird yeah
left-footed really uh-huh it was a i had
this like nightmarish teacher in
primary school in australia i went to a
catholic primary school i guess it was
christian actually this is cool
and because i was right-handed and i
kept failing
at it was high jump that i was trying to
do i just my brain just couldn't do high
jump being on the right side of it
and she she just bullied the [ __ ] out of
me and then we changed teachers one day
and the second teacher was just like
oh you're probably just left-footed and
it was like so weird having this teacher
who was like why aren't you doing this
right i don't understand what's wrong
with you and then another teacher just
being like oh you just have to use your
left foot and then i was really good at
high jump but i was like god damn
the difference between these two humans
and one of them was it was her name was
mrs maloney
it's an [ __ ] she also called me dirty
because i'm not
um uh i'm not what's the word baptized
but i still went to a catholic school
and she was like you are filthy i was
like
[Music]
i'm literally today years old when i
learned that you had a dominant foot i
did not know that
yeah yeah oh yeah of course well no
there's no of course to it because if
you're if you're disabled there's
certain things you don't know
sure that's one of them true you're good
you're right
to call me on that i mean you think
about like why some you know like again
go back to you know liverpool today like
there's a reason why some
uh players play on the left or on the
right because their dominant foot
dictates
yeah there was an interesting thing
about uh playing baseball like in high
school or middle school
where if you were our left-handed
thrower coaches are like you're
immediately a pitcher i don't care what
you do i don't care how fast you throw
it you're gonna be a pitcher why
because it's so hard to hit against a
left-hander if you don't really
recognize it immediately
interesting
is it right-handed
i couldn't tell if you were still
talking because that you broke up for a
second yeah that was weird yeah
um no i was just saying yeah um if you
pitch if you're left-handed they would
make you a pitcher
it's crazy [ __ ] it would force you
so yeah so when i when i was i'm old
enough that when i was like in first and
second grade at school in london
left-handedness was still considered
something that was needed to be
corrected
they tried to force me to write with my
right hand and my mother went down to
the school and read them the [ __ ]
riot act
it's messed up that they're like you
know
i feel like that's just such a good
lesson and how hard we try to make
people conform
yeah change your dominant hand damn it
like it's crazy to do that to kids
i'm just really happy to hear somebody
else who says the words read on the
right
sometimes you gotta read them the riot
act you know that's what's up
oh we had 18 thousand dollars my
favorite one
i know i keep thinking about football i
guess because premier league's back
today but like my favorite one the llama
might know this one is called
alex ferguson he used to be the manager
of manchester united i know alex
ferguson
for giving his players when he wasn't
happy with the performance he he gave
him what they called the hairdryer
which was like he shouts in their face
so much that it's like a hairdryer
blowing in your face
basically like blowing your hair back
yikes oopsie daisy i enjoy this one
me too yeah i like a good hoopsie daisy
i don't have any negative feelings
it's nice to not have negative feelings
towards things i mean i try i try
a huge thing okay i have negative
feelings towards that because that was
not correct
i got through before that guy in fact
i'm going to give myself that hoot and
it's realistic all right well there's
two of us on here
yeah we have one more than the
this just feels useless for me right now
you guys i'm not i'm not contributing to
the team and i should be scalding oh god
if you guys like wanted to kick me out
i'm not contributing either
no wonder we're [ __ ] right now i'm doing
real bad i am i
i'm doing real fast hang on i'm about to
get in okay we need a [ __ ] we need a
lava
you piece of [ __ ] you stupid [ __ ]
oh my god are you talking to yourself or
some other player
no definitely oh i also tried to get up
there and i fell
oh you got it get it andy he did get it
thank god for andy cortes
we need a clutch player here we're still
well okay this is mine
we can maybe get i think we should
spread out a bit y'all i think that uh
we're a little bit too uh yellow
bad news gary yellow yeah no
yellow
no neither it's all andy and steve just
steve is still interested
yeah i mean dude this match is just all
about domination you just
yeah total domination make them bend to
your will you know what i mean
how does that apply though like how do
you really do that while jumping through
hoops you know you know what i'm saying
or being
here one gold hoop can turn this all
around so
stay on mine oh we headbutted in the
middle
yellow got it
if yellow gets a gold we're [ __ ] okay
we're good oh gosh
it wasn't great it wasn't great it
wasn't great but
we done did it good job middle guy thank
god for middle guy thank you guys thank
you
i did have some drop frames there can't
confirm
chat noticed it too there was some it's
true
uh that's someone posting ascii titties
in my chat
oh congrats yeah it's huge for you
you start asking titties no ascii
oh i thought we were asking about them
sorry yeah okay
titties even to twitter and alana
kept talking about uh football
how do you feel about america uh i i am
sad that we're going back because
pandemic but
what is actually happening with the nfl
are is it going ahead they're going
they're going back to full board
not with no not with crowds though right
45
population oh okay 25
it does feel like a bad idea but if
there's anything i've learned you know
gary especially being foreign in this
country during a pandemic is that they
do not give
a [ __ ] i feel like it could be forward
no it's not forward it's
left
in jacksonville have fans the other
teams have decided not to
oh right okay so only some stadiums are
doing it that's interesting
cowboys decided that they're so they
were gonna do full
they were gonna do all the fans and then
they decided no fans and now they're
thinking about some fans
in october they're apparently dallas is
adding fans in october
there we go probably won't happen yeah
because everything will be fine by then
yeah yeah who's left in me
me you and me uh wait three of yeah okay
all right well there's a whole shot shot
a team crown here and jump showdown
this is the one that i'm best at people
always watching out for grabbing people
you should trap even a woman at a
nightclub gary
that should just be a lesson no matter
what it's true
yeah anyway but i tell you being being a
dj
the the periods where i have to go to
the bathroom and you have to walk
through like sometimes several dance
floors to get to a bathroom if it's a
large club
it's just a bad time it's
not good you're gonna have a bad time i
started having security come with me
i've been on every platform that's about
yeah this is scared
they're dropping in it probably hurts
the death yeah
but it does mean we don't get separated
which yeah yeah yeah
okay there's the separation now yep oh
boy
could be bad for all three of us one of
us really should have gone on the other
side of that split
no we're good and you've gone over there
oh [ __ ] zero jump over there okay okay
now
couple of people fell oh no i ain't even
grabbed it you really really need the
other
this platform dropped okay okay it's
gonna be
it's gonna be split [ __ ] oh my gosh
oh my gosh
you ready for this i don't care you got
to get them all oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god
let's just get that banana wait is is
another one
not gonna shake no
oh it's only two [ __ ] okay
all you do now is jump all you got to do
now is jump i'm so nervous
oh [ __ ] this is family time i'm instead
of chance
okay come on okay okay andy okay andy
here's what i'm going to do that's what
he decided to do
oh there were three others though
that was on alice yeah the
alignment was with some [ __ ] there was a
guy at the end of a round who
we were going for so long that he just
even went to bed
he held on to whoever hits the water
first he held on to me and i hit the
water first
yeah we had a good we had a good we got
a good shot at that yeah i guess we suck
um the fact that we had such a good shot
and that's what happened means when it
may be really bad
that's another final round that's true
the moon
it's all counts of progress that's true
in the twitch rivals you don't even have
to win crowns you just have to make it
to the final
oh okay then yeah white pro game is
that's what's up
still wasn't a very good play behind me
no it was really bad i tapped over to
you and immediately and you were like
here's what i'm gonna do and then you
just yeet it off the side
it was pretty funny though it was funny
we appreciate that
i don't know why we keep talking about
it you know maybe if it went so bad then
we wouldn't
keep discussing it that's fine
we did have 18 000 though everyone thank
you so much that's the best
that's actually really 14 000. what are
you raising
what are you raising money for again i
forgot i'm glad you are steve i'm
raising money for
the american red cross uh disaster
relief to assist
uh with containing the fires that are
blazing across the west coast of the us
right now
oh that's amazing is there anything that
i could donate to that
yeah you could go to the link that's in
the description on youtube and also i
don't [ __ ] know the panel area on
twitch i don't understand the twitch ui
it's bad but the link is there and also
scooterman gaming whom in my chat is
repeatedly linking it out he really does
a lot of work
i opened up the tweet is what i did and
then i donated fifty dollars and i put
[ __ ] fire
all right cash money hero damn yeah
tweet also yeah
yeah i owe my homies yeah the nitro
rifle money you can afford
it's true it's true exactly yeah
absolutely me and my giant mansion i
always like making jokes at like
this is just my streaming room not my
bedroom
just has a bed in it for naps between
streams
yeah i guess i could say that about my
studio apartment no bro this is just my
streaming room it's not my entire
apartment
don't worry about it yeah this giant one
room
yeah it's just my streaming room i i
just happen to have a kitchen and a bed
and a tv idiot but it's just my stream
room bro it's chill yeah
i do my laundry name yeah i don't have
to i don't have any other room
i'm [ __ ] here this is so bad did you
fall off the side is that you
oh no that's steve that's how steve yeah
i got the coolest of cats
come out of your pitching i know
sometimes you just gotta
sometimes you just gotta [ __ ] talk a
pigeon dude
sometimes they need to hear not do that
friendship ended with fire
fire will remember that poor lana and
her shadow bands are you still not
popping up on twitch what's going on
i think i'm alright on twitch tonight i
don't know i do get shadow bands just
whenever
yeah that definitely happened to you one
time it's happened like three times i
think it's brutal now i have 910 people
here right now i think that would
generally mean we ain't shadow man
are we uh are we all through yeah yeah
okay oh yeah we're all getting a bunch
of qualifiers out here
i'm checking a bunch of lost around
heroes why are we not in church rivals
is this team i don't know
it's a great question i think there's a
lot of politics probably politics
involved
it's all it's all politics yeah we have
a woman a person of color
and someone who's disabled so yeah
that's too diverse yeah
but you're not two white man i can't
carry the whole team to political safety
by myself
political safety
it's true it's true obama oh these guys
are getting grieved oh dude
oh creepy creepy hard bro
i really like this song yeah i like the
color i have music off
it's like oh that's the music yeah
that's so sad
andy i've played enough are you a
sociopath i just
i i'll have automatic gucci on the
background you know i never trusted you
anyway but now i trust you even less
than i had before
he says he doesn't like the whole guys
yeah what the [ __ ] is wrong with you bro
yeah i've had enough of it you know
music you know the music gets you just
had enough of music
and dogs yeah really sweet music wow
i'm just kind of curious is anyone
because i've not i don't think i've
spoken to either of you
uh or any of you about this topic but to
many others i have do any of you does
anyone here
uh disagree uh
i'm getting with with my contention that
fall guys is a necessary component of
any game of the year
i just got pushed off um no it i
absolutely think that this is uh
i gotta you lived but it's it won't win
but it will be nominated
i gotta live i mean i think you'll win a
bunch of categories and i i
and again i personally think it's no
question it's my game
no not even close really i i think it
should be on
every shortlist for the overall game of
the year
yeah i think it should be too if they
had paid attention to accessibility i'd
agree with you
what what what what's what's on the top
of your accessibility wish list steve
they they completely left out controller
support remapping which is two of the
big ones i don't even understand how the
game got released without those two
options you can't right
anything to a mouse i mean i know that
you know because we had the devs on our
show
and they they talked about a bunch of
accessibility stuff like
they got called out and they got called
out on a colorblind mode which they
admitted they need to put in the game
that was you right oh i i
yeah i mean i was uh so i guess i can
talk about this now we weren't because
it was gonna happen but i was heralding
a accessibility awards this year through
checkpoint that i was like very excited
to put together
uh but we were going to have it be a
live pax west thing and had sponsors
planned and you know i'm gonna do this
whole thing and then got pandemic
and i'm trying to figure out if there's
a way that i can still put together an
accessibility awards
um of some kind because i feel like the
industry having
things that are like obviously we need
people like you steve to to
call them out when they're being bad but
also to have like an organized thing for
when games are very good
like gears five or last part two
like to to be like this is very good at
this then maybe other devs will have
more incentive to think about it so i'm
trying to figure out if there's a way
that i can still do that remotely
um the checkpoint team is no longer able
to support me
time wise on it because again everyone
got pandemic but
hopefully i can still figure something
out that obviously i would uh
i would lean on you for some help nasty
but
what got to figure out where it would
exist and what the platform would be and
all that stuff but yeah we were trying
it it's so hard
it's a hard subject because it's you
know what's successful
you couldn't stop me could you use that
pigeon
[Laughter]
you tried we're in trouble here we need
to be targeting blue right now man red
is just owning the game forget about red
who's even here gary what what's your
number
what's my number oh yeah fourteen four
seven eight
this dude has egg on his feet yeah you
saw that right a little wolf guy
i think no he's a pigeon oh yeah yeah
the other animal
yes the only tomato in the game as far
as i can oh that's right here's the
tomato clutch here for blue and yellow
you know that steve it's tomato thank
you
not tomato i don't know
okay we need this this needs to work
come on
oh they got a goal
[Music]
i did everything i could yeah i hate to
see it i did everything there's not much
more you could do there gary we're
dropping out
i left it all out on the field
you were hard carrying the team wasn't
that steven that threw you off
no because the person the cat that i
knocked off
ah steve wouldn't do that no i was busy
fighting my own cat
yeah yeah yeah there was a there was a
cat that tried to grief me early on and
then
i griefed them back and we both fell in
love together and it was po
it was poetry is alana in oh no
everybody lost we all lost yeah no i
dropped i dropped out
yeah i actually really actually really
don't like the griefing in this game i
know gary's going through the dark side
slowly but i'm not
i'm just not i got it i got to tell you
i was so ashamed i straight up griefed
someone for the first time yesterday
and i liked it thank you josh that's
that's like the katy perry song
i grieved a full guy and i liked it yeah
i was ashamed of myself no i won't do it
but it felt good
no i don't i don't ashamed that it felt
don't like it
yeah you should be ashamed you're a
monster i think my my favorite one was
on
slime climb that i saw at the very very
end with the two big
swinging sort of like boulders that are
gonna hit you fine i'll say balls you
children i'll say this big two swinging
balls
um uh snow bike mike was waiting for a
guy and somebody mike is like grappling
with this dude
and then he pushes him to the ball and
the ball knocks him off and it was just
like
man that's gotta feel great like you
know what it was funny alana you would
never know this because like
snowbite mike oh give me something early
like he's like so positive and he's in
his like energy
truly just such a lovely man but he is
but as a gamer
my god really griefer
exploits really whatever it takes oh my
god but i've i mean i've played games
with him and he's still very positive
is he just very positive in his griefing
i mean he's like the joker like he's got
a smile on his face while he
sticks the knife
sometimes it's chaos i respect that yeah
i respect it
yeah picking up what he's putting down
he's he's a gamer
he's a gamer bro and the gamer knows
that to win sometimes you have to grief
but also he's been he has been casting a
lot of these big fall guys tournaments
that's so cool and and and because of
that he's been watching these really
really good players
i got to start watching some
for sure god doesn't really like this
one
oh sorry i've maybe confused the many
dude streamers that i don't know who
they are and maybe i'm thinking of lip
balm
first person shooter god he has been
playing a lot of fall guys the funny
thing about it is like shroud
well i don't find shroud terribly
interesting to watch but he's obviously
like an elite level player
but he's so composed and calm that i
don't find him that interesting for once
but like when he plays four guys he
[ __ ] rages like everybody else yeah
because this game won't make anybody
better yeah yeah yeah it's true
games are really big i've never raged
with this game shut up chat
i don't think that's true i don't think
that's true i think i've seen the reach
so
it's always an easy quality good one
it's a good one i bet we get slime climb
now and i'm out in the first five
minutes let's go slam playing let's go
slime
climb you haven't had fruit shoes bring
it over yeah
there's a ton of games we have yeah oh
my god i love jinx jerry gary
we haven't had uh rock and roll which i
really like
which one's rock and roll that's the one
where you just have to roll the big ball
down the chute oh yeah
yeah you like poopsy daisy that's a team
game
yeah i guess so qed oh my god that
didn't i got an achievement
two achievements for something just now
all right there's a lot of dumb
achievements like falling tent out
and then i did a backflip oh wait a way
to just immediately invalidate my
achievement gary
just didn't even know what it was he's
like there's lots of dumb ones so
it's probably a stupid one
yeah whatever one you just don't know
what it was stupid oh man you didn't
even know what it was
oh heck
you know what i really really don't like
about playstation trophies as opposed to
xbox achievements
is they don't tell you what you actually
achieved like the extremely much one to
do
so like oh when it pops out yeah and
yeah when it pops up it'll say like 50
gamers or whatever
you know uh [ __ ] [ __ ] a fairy or
whatever the name yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
sure yeah and then and then it will say
like yeah you ship up to 20 fairies
yeah so i get that but the playstation
when you have to tab out of the game
instead of
see what it is into the ui to see what
it is i will say though every time i get
a diamond achievement it's like a
[ __ ] jump scare
like oh my god because it's so
aggressive and loud
yeah it is so loud oftentimes i think
achievement pops at times that really
break immersion in games
yeah and if i was a developer i'd be
pissed about that
well you can choose where you want to
put them though i know but i and i would
be really picky about it because like i
don't want popping
like you don't want i've seen them pop
up like in the middle of cinematics
because like
and a trophy could just be like complete
act one of the story
you made that right stephen you made
that i made it not only did i make it
with the guy that was trying to grace me
got left
out sucker insta karma
uh yeah i like a good achievement but
there are there are some games that uh
this game that i was playing recently
where it's like the achievement would
require you tapping a for about 12 hours
um and i would do dumb achievements just
to get them yeah i was like i'm not
gonna
do that i'm not gonna do that i don't do
things i don't enjoy i just tend to look
at the achievements list
after i finish a game if i already like
it and be like if i get
if i naturally get achievements and
trophies along the mind the way of my
natural course of playing the game
great but i will not go out on my way
for them i will if i like the game and i
want more content
go ahead yeah the only time the only
time i've ever like even
platinum the game and my wife helped me
do it because there's a couple of things
that were really [ __ ] me up some of
the time challenges
was uh spiderman because i actually
enjoyed going and getting all the
backpacks but like usually i hate doing
that collectible [ __ ] yeah
it seems like spider-man it's kind of
everybody's favorite platinum you guys
have been talking about steve for like a
minute steve what do you want to do
what do you want to say that is my
greatest argument behind
pc versus console because if you're not
somebody who likes to
uh deal with platinuming an entire game
i think that's why a lot of us who love
pc more
yeah steam has achievements but nobody
cares
no i don't care about them at all no
nobody does yeah
no one even understands it's true
because then if you're playing on pc you
can avoid that
pull for like a couple of people in
trouble bye bye mr pirate
yeah i've actually gotten cleaned up on
this one recently because my feet will
get stuck underneath
this thing it's
yeah and just like out of nowhere but
like before that started happening this
one was really easy to just
oh [ __ ] over here get over here gary get
over here i think the first time that i
experienced like a diamond achievement
or whatever they call them on xbox
i think it was the outer worlds or or
the outer wilds either one of them
okay one of those is the one where
you're in a spaceship and the other one
is when you're in a spaceship but you
don't have to control it
i'm also dead gary gary gary gary uh i
fully died
yeah it smeared the [ __ ] out of me it
was so loud yeah they were really
aggressive
yeah oh yeah it's a different sound
isn't it for the super rare ones
yeah stevie you 1644
no um 20 80 something
20 80. you're the one with the colorful
pants right that one that one wasn't so
bad
colorful pants yep i made it well it
wasn't so bad well
andy and i both didn't make it yes when
you say my audio up do you mean my voice
or like the game
audio or what i'm sorry i
had just looked away and then i looked
at my chat and someone said i get what
you're saying but i don't think
comparing those three games is like
comparing dark souls to mario i'm sorry
what
what have i missed what are you guys
talking about
i agree with that and sure oh okay
i think they're talking about the last
part too it happens
i turned my gain up hopefully you'll be
able to hear me i think my wife really
wants me to hear my voice
ooh full ball all right
let's do it okay here we go this is like
a real team game here
let's go let's get it done
get it done getting it done
i believe in you the tomato head is so
cute because it's so shiny i love it
it looks nice and blue actually yeah
nice blue tomato
can't be healthy but it looks good
oh oh oh that one almost went in
that's why almost all food and add
science fiction is blue
because it's the color that it's the
color that occurs least common
common food yeah so when you see blue
food you must think it's exotic doesn't
it
trying to think of any blue foods i mean
there's blueberries
yeah but even those like barely look
blue they're like a little blackberries
i'm saying it's the least by far the
least common color yeah but i'm trying
to think of like
and in nature in general that even exist
the sky oh oh denied by my own blood oh
nice
[Music]
oh i had a beautiful head again i saw
what you were going for there steve
yep yep yep right into the rip waiting
for the rip okay 2-1
oh steve oh i cannot lose this we cannot
lose this
i really want to win this game you could
oh [ __ ]
no this one gold lead is not enough of a
cushion i need more ah
watch the left this needs to be in
manchester city we're not a little
chicken
you need to be confident not terrified
the whole time i understand what you're
saying
no i mean we need to win by a lot of
goals not just one okay we sometimes win
by a lot of goals all right but the
thing is that you're always terrified
you're just gonna get taken away from me
we've had some wins okay all right okay
i'm not i'm not down you have wins i
mean that much is evident i'm just
saying a lot of them are very narrow
squeaker wins it is true
it is true very stressful uh club to be
a supporter of
i mean like like case in point today
against a recently promoted team
yeah fortress anfield yep well yeah but
anfield is in anfield right now
you know i guess you know what i'm
saying doesn't even count
i mean yeah the cop is certainly not the
cop man
oh this looks good oh i'm waiting for an
opportunity back here i'm just waiting
lurking coach waiting for a pouch
damn good defense from them though this
is really
oh you'll get that one come on surely no
they they can't equalize the time now we
got it no they can't
not with those two right there oh well
that was a close one there was a close
one
it got spicy
tension i've had playing four balls we
usually win by a lot
uh-huh uh-huh are we all still in
no it's just you and steve oh [ __ ] okay
sometimes
they need a little thing on the side
that tells you like on your squad like
who's still in
agreement yeah i mean there's a bunch of
stuff they need to add to this game
that they will oh
here we go again come on steve we got
this stephen gary
nope mm-hmm when in the lobby which one
is stephen again
uh i am the egg with the cat oh the cat
right of course yeah
you've got an arrow over here
oh nope i want to jump out
oh okay straight i'm strangely calm
not usually this calm in the final round
usually a bag of nerves
yeah it immediately hits my stomach oh
it's gonna it's gonna split
thank you psi red eye you just said
charity thank you that chicken has taken
a big risk hanging out over there by
himself
okay we're all together now oh he came
over yeah yeah okay he made the hero
jump
yeah there goes that platform okay okay
now the middle one could drop that would
be interesting
um
all right good luck wait has nobody been
eliminated yet
very very close there
and there again
[Music]
oh my god okay there goes the duck
oh it's yeah
he's gonna line up the wrong way in just
a second yeah
still all right right now steve doesn't
even have to move either oh oh
no you're good you're good you're good
yeah okay you avoided it again
this one's not ideal no it's okay it's
okay that one's not bad there's a little
gap there
oh this one might be bad yeah that's bad
no we got it
that one's okay okay
how long can it last this one's not
yeah he's driving hard yeah
yeah he's grabbing big time oh wow he
did he's
daddy is he honestly a very good tactic
it worked
i mean he's almost helping you but he's
gonna grab you two to help that cat
oh my god gary oh my god gary this guy
no oh
god damn it [ __ ] duck
i mean it's like i said i can't even be
mad at the guy because that's a
it's all in the game it's valid
and the thing is it's not easy to pull
off you can you can get yourself jammed
up doing that if you don't know how to
do it right
yeah no is andy off like floating with
his chat or something like what's
happening
yeah sometimes he goes i've
[Applause]
making yourself look pretty for a minute
so you can get that cash money is that
what's happening
i try to yeah you like batting your
eyelids and
yeah nice nice good strap bro i'm gonna
guess this is from alana's show because
it seems like thank you seven to seven
minutes probably someone missed him for
another
half hour three different people came
over yeah
the uh the the uh the poop trio they're
in my chat all the time
they're gary though i think cyclone and
um
uh poop funnel i can't remember the name
there's three of them
yeah they always show up in in as as
three
yeah i don't i don't mind them because
they drop subs in the channel
the [ __ ] drops sub so we like them yeah
check it out oh i got to say that last
one i i wanted that one
i wanted that one i'm a little bit
bummed about that yeah especially
because you got like a griefer who won
that is that is devastating
again i i can't call it griefing in on
that level like it's that's just
it's it's baked in i mean it it is for
valentine's
day it's like it's like winning by
focusing on i mean it's a negative
strategy that's not like the worst thing
i could say about it but at the end of
the day
it's all about getting them crowns i
think when you're in the last round it's
kind of anyone's game like that's the
only time where i'm like
i get it you gotta get people eliminated
to win i would i would do it to a squad
member
all bets are off in the final wow okay
gary noted
wow was going to throw him out yeah
pretty crazy
i'm your best buddy until the final
round i didn't think he was like this
guys
yeah i mean i'm just i'm being upfront
about it i
you know look i appreciate your honesty
but i'm very i'm very open about
what you see is what you get
oh [ __ ] my [ __ ] are you kidding me
here we go oh no what's it gonna take to
get this okay steve
cool yeah just run away from me there
son of a [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] believable gamers chat man
you guys are real far back there
y'all dude oh my god what the [ __ ] andy
i just saw you how did you even do that
i had like the highest
drop oh my
i just hate this stupid purple oh i like
it for me
this level some like best typifies what
fall guys
is yeah
[ __ ] i feel like a lot of the
early levels do that for me whether it's
whirly gig and all those
thank you yeah but none of those drive
you nuts and you can't say that it's a
quintessentially four guys level unless
it's doing that
true i think this is the only one that
drives me nuts
oh this is i am gonna call oh so that's
okay
we got the quad i'm not gonna make it
was this like this wasn't the first one
was it
this was around i don't know we'll see
in a second
round two maybe i don't know
[Music]
okay no that was round one was it do we
want to
drop out yeah then drop it out drop it
out drop it out
then
one of my mods caught in spectate mode
for a second here
will tell you one of the crowns i want
tonight i beat a hacker yes
it's so satisfying oh it's the best well
then on another one
a hacker dove like just completely
[ __ ] up and fell
immediately into slime on slime plan the
thing is they're incompetent
they're not even good at hacking yeah
well if you're gonna do it at least do
it well and properly
i i did see uh in one of the crown
mountains on where somebody
was flying around and they were unable
to catch the crown
they kept going up and down why they're
not letting me out of here
why is it still spectacular
uh we had 18 500. you guys look at this
i have actually i i had someone say that
the other day
the last time i played we did a fun
house stream on friday and um connor
wasn't able to point out this game
yeah that is a a bug
all right i'm gonna have to restart the
game i'll be right back real weird
but it is a thing
[Music]
just no you've got the guy fieri screen
you are a basic [ __ ] though so
yeah that's true that's a good plan
that's a good point no i'm just glad you
said it
yeah someone if i just said andy is for
sure not cool
oh jesus wow i was thinking it too
thank you perfect honestly i get that
from a lot of like fun house fans
it's okay but what you get is that
you're not cool
it could be a lot worse sure oh no of
course yeah yeah
being uncool is pretty chill out of his
just like oh oh that's fat rahul coley
like i've gotten that
andy is probably the coolest person that
kind of funny i would say
andy is the coolest
you do that i got you
well who shot you wait uh way to kick me
out that's right i didn't kick anybody
out
what are you talking about there he is
he's back he's back honestly
it's because um steven questioned
the asterisk when
i mean doesn't everybody know honestly i
mean
when you see an asterisk you want to
know you're very much in the minority in
questioning it
the vast majority of people are on my
side over this and gary's not at all
defensive about it
no no no let me ask you guys it's not a
tough one i'm honestly i'm honestly not
i'm so secure in it
i'm so utterly secure are you like yeah
that's definitely legit
but there won't be an app but there
won't be an asterisk i mean they said
but andy said there was so
i didn't say there was i didn't ever i
didn't ever say there was steven
i said right let's roll let's roll back
the tape it's
there's no there's no way you can look
at that clip and come to
any other any other conclusion i am on
team gary in this one
thank you yeah and so am i i'm just
saying think you know
are you gary yep yeah yeah is the only
one being contrarian about it
nope well that's steve you know hard to
please
on twitter talking about how games need
to be more accessible who do you think
you are always always always complaining
just accept what you're given you have
it so easy
yeah i just want to be able to play the
game
get out of here steve
i would love to just literally be able
to play it entitled
that's me they're like
wow
so i'm not actually in your game wait
what
yeah how did that seriously i'm i'm at
the lobby i'm literally looking
at it should we go back now
yeah i can quit get out of here i'm
having a beautiful seesaw running
you are here though but you are i mean
i mean i'm in the group
but i'm not in that group i don't know
this is weird yeah you you were just
staring at our four bodies standing on
the pencils oh
how strange i don't know this this game
has some things sometimes
very curious just waiting on andy to
ready up
oh sorry another thing i want him to and
it's such a tiny thing but when you drop
as a squad i think you should
look like you're dropping as a squad
yeah that's that's fair
that's a time it's a tiny cosmetic thing
but it would make me happy
you want us all to be tomatoes no i i
want us
i want to see all of our characters all
four of them together yeah like every
other battle royale
because this is a battle royale it's
see-saw again are you here steve
i am okay okay all right so now i will
now have you guys
two perfect seesaw runs in a row yeah i
was doing pretty well that time actually
well then he says andy honestly
discovered you from the adventure series
from funhouse what no not all fun house
fans hate me confirm
they hate everyone though it's fine it's
it's kind of their chop it's what we've
bred into them because we hate each
other as well so they you know just grew
from our
our culture oh well controller whoa whoa
buddy what's going on it just stopped
letting me
my um okay
oh yikes you want to see rage oh my
goodness
that i just that was just me i just
[ __ ] that up there's almost no way i'm
going to
make this work with that control error
um
but maybe i can pull it through i'm
doing it very impressive right if i must
say so myself
disagree really no i was meaning to tell
you how bad it is
you just [ __ ]
i'm having a decent round i i every time
i say something like that though it's
like
yeah yeah your player is gonna just
self-destruct
jelly bean guts all over the world i got
grabbed [ __ ] grabbed me
serious black says andy can you i don't
know how many takes of stuff she has to
shoot when john smith is involved
we don't operate that way
at a yield fund house
people do no
the increase in in chaotic takes is a
plus
[ __ ] i shouldn't have gone for it not a
negative so uh
we don't do takes at all at funhouse
even if someone's tech isn't working we
just keep it in the edit
lazy is uh what i'm trying to say really
i like it extremely lazy oh no
i saw that steve i'm also on that
platform
here's tomato head oh no that's right
trying to find um i'm not gonna make it
i'm not gonna make it
yeah it's fair but i was going to say i
don't deserve that one but it was a
controller problem so
that probably just a general note from
my chat
gary you should dive when you jump it
helps a lot is not something someone
with 21 crowns needs to bring up
i had that before they told me that
before too and i'm like [ __ ] you think
i don't know this
i played a lot of this game and i'm bad
at it but i know
it's not for lack of information it's
never bothered me except in this game it
really annoys me i don't know why that
is my favorite one
ever was playing i was doing my stream
of the last of us two the full play
through and
some guy was like annie the bow and
arrows are stealth they're quiet
people are trying to be helpful the
worst i ever get is and it makes me not
do it on stream anymore if you play a
game
uh on the hardest difficulty and people
even if i have it in the title
they'll be like i don't understand why
you're dying so quickly like what's
wrong with the game
and be like it's the hardest difficulty
so i did no man's sky on survival which
is brutal like often you can't even get
off the first planet
people are like you need oxygen and i'm
like it's the hardest part
we went back to the lobby why is adam's
and he's still playing yeah what the
[ __ ] andy
i'm in wow yeah that's right what the
[ __ ] bro
and he just plowed plowed ahead wow
uh you need to come back to the lobby
again sorry
the adhd took over and i was like oh
yeah back out and then something else
happened and i got distracted
i'm just coming off your single player
games on screen i just
i i i was really having a lot of fun
playing um
odyssey and and the assassin's creed
world was really cool i love the
roman greek mythology is super like into
it and then someone just comes out and
goes man what do you think at the end of
it one of them in this like the second
quest
and like if i say end of it i mean they
described the ending scene and i'm like
that's not great yeah that's a ban
i am like extremely strict about that
when we were
obviously spoilers philosophers too had
already leaked but i was doing a
playthrough of the last plus one before
part two came out
and during part one like we are on sub
only mode
um we have mods just always just
monitoring and it's like i'm none of
that here dude and and also i don't even
want hints
i don't want theories i don't want you
to incept an idea into my brain right
yeah it's it's a mess
that happened to me with uh with the
recent marvel big
sad news i'm gonna walk around there
just in case some rules but
uh the sad news the door on the right is
the one that will open at the end
thanks um but i literally my mods but
because i hadn't seen the news yet so
they put in a bunch of things okay you
know
from coming through they stay they they
keyboarded it out they really tried to
protect me as best that they could
and i'm like okay i can see all doing
words and i'm kind of piecing it
together here
but uh i'm not entirely sure and then
i'm like but you know what's gonna
happen it's not gonna be a random
it's gonna be someone who gives gift
subs all the time and someone we're not
expecting it from within 20 minutes
someone who gives gifts of a little time
i was like man um
yeah so then now i'm trying to process
sad news live on the air and like all
right yeah that's a bit tough
i cried one time on a stream which i'm
not proud of but to be fair it was
because we got like
i think it was like somebody donated
like ten thousand dollars on a charity
stream
and i just ended up crying because it
was so nice but i was like i still kind
of wish that wasn't
a thing that i did live on the internet
i might not call this time classic gary
terrible
this is a you're not an easy question
back for the lobby i'm sorry what are
you saying
i'm sorry it happens to the best of us
and you as you can see because it just
happened we have to forfeit right
yes round one
okay apparently i'm trapped no wait that
was round two i think that was round two
yeah that was around because we did a
see-saw
but i already quit so i guess i'll go
[ __ ] myself now i feel like a total dope
sorry
okay now i feel like a total i was
around
i would have never tried it that's fine
i would have never guessed that was
round
two if you're watching in squad stream
mode you can watch uh andy play i
went back to the lobby so i'm not
spectating oh andy's still playing
it takes me a while bro bro
i'm gonna we're exiting out right now
yeah
okay oh andy is okay i thought
he was i thought he was gonna keep going
andy and i are both in but we're gonna
pull out
oh me and stephen no let's stay here
let's stay here
keep going if you want it's fine if it
was just me i would have said no
i would have loved to have stayed in
this so that would have been yeah that
would have been sick it would be cool if
you're here yeah
yeah all right i get it super cool but i
left because someone told me to so i
guess
that's cool are there watermelons and
tomatoes this is not the positive
team chemistry that is essential yeah
well
you're not going to get a team crown
when one of you tells the other one to
drop out are you gary
all right and normal and
recriminations either
that's fair um sf fire the donations in
the youtube chat will
will not count towards the charity so
what i do because it goes through
youtube and i don't get it for a month
what i do is collect those later and
donate them to charity
but they won't count to the time you
have to go to the link in the
description
the most embarrassing thing happened to
me and gary earlier we were talking [ __ ]
about this really
screwman gaming i'm planning to publish
the edited version of the list on the
20th
should be there yeah for some reason
there were like 10 of us on the right i
don't know how many
i think it's like a critical mass thing
like one person gets it wrong yeah
and so someone else goes well he must
have it right and then they then see two
people
and like it's there's actually like i
know some fascinating like oh no
theory of crowds thing going on in this
game
oh does he have it no he doesn't have it
hey pj uh i feel like every time that
i'm seeing you
type something it's negative um so you
[ __ ] [ __ ] out mate
stop being a [ __ ] and then everybody
went to the one right beside it so it
panicked me so i walked to it and it was
not the right one and it equaled me i
was like
i i just got baited when i knew the
answer already i don't know why my brain
just did this
my issue with it is is if other people
recite
audibly like if i'm playing in a squad i
completely lose all ability to remember
where the things are
alive i i i'm whispering in my head yeah
you have to be my friend adam calls it
he goes okay melon here banana then i'm
like will you shut the [ __ ] up i'm
trying to
do my own thing over here do it all
around the reason why i died right there
is because i was telling the story of
how me and gary [ __ ] up
wait so you guys are you guys
oh steve's still in okay
okay steve's the only the other ones he
keeps forgetting about me kind of hurts
my feelings a little bit
i know i just thought that we all you
know in solidarity had exited out when i
when i you know mr albeit mistakenly
said so
i mean some people just want to keep
going i guess listen the nitro rifle
tells you to do something you listen
so sad respect what are you no
oh no steven's okay never mind yeah
how are we looking i'm gonna go to
steven's stream
okay i believe in you steve i believe in
you thank you
get that done only a matter of time
where are you at here you go who wins
heater celtics i think the heat win
who who's that uh a national basketball
association it's a
it's a game um it's like a little
start-up that's
all yeah like like an indie type thing
yeah it's a little indie thing there's a
couple of leagues running around these
might take awful
it's possible with the right like
kickstarter backing yeah possible
that'd be tight it'd be tight good luck
good luck
yeah i hate to see it i can't i can't
handle pineapples
you can't handle the pineapple that's
that's basically how eminem sounds when
he raps
can't handle the pineapple
are we are we going that's a good job
yeah yeah
[Music]
uh chad is asking if i banned the word
simp
i have never banned a word on twitch so
i didn't ban it
someone else has to have one time i
allowed the phrase white supremacy
accidentally
no it was it was like white power or
something because somebody made a joke
and i was like oh it flagged that let me
allow it while i was drunk
and then it like just came up and was
like you have a loud white power and i
was like no no no no no
no no no no no this is what i wanted to
do
yeah it was bad it's a bad time
no i'm from pittsburgh so i totally
don't understand basketball in any
sense of the word picture something
black and yellow black and yellow black
and yellow yeah
i am with uh hockey
yeah it's true story the first time i
ever met andy
we're sitting across from each other at
a like a giant
cute date you guys keep calling first
thing it was amazing yeah
and then he changed about me and it kind
of sucked andy what the [ __ ]
he's like so basketball like what are
you like i'm a spurs guy what do you
think and i was like
um i taught him yeah i taught him
and then that's why andy cheated he had
to didn't have a choice after that
i ended up dating the other one that was
a basketball fan yeah
the other guy named steve gary's a
supposed fan right you're a supposed fan
aren't you gary a real suspect i'm a
tottenham hustler fan they play
everything tomorrow
not the hotspur we're talking about the
sanatorium no you're talking about dogs
but
i'm nba what time are they playing gary
i'm sorry what time are they playing i
think they're playing 8 30 tomorrow
morning our time okay
come on watch that tottenham's my number
two team which i know you're not allowed
to have but i don't care about the rules
of football
you don't have you're not allowed that
you're not allowed that you're
absolutely
how did they end up as your number two
team my dad's team
oh okay yeah so how did liverpool end up
as your number one i know you told me
this before but how did they end up as
your number one team there's a lot of
australians like it's very common i
would say they are the most supportive
team in australia because there was an
australian player in the league
it seems like it seems like spurs being
your dad team would still override that
well in theory but then
you know my grandad his team was um
united okay so it's like they're kind of
across the board but right now
uh we've got more liverpool fans in the
family than
spurs fans um but they still have my
respect
because my granddad was still around he
wouldn't be too thrilled about that
this it's it's odd though because my
dad's convinced that he was a spurs fan
but my mom's convinced that he was a
united fan and i'm like i feel like
i probably listened to mum but i prefer
to believe that dad is correct
but i don't i don't remember oh yeah he
does a latest fan that's cool
yeah how does he feel about jugg and
club
no but i could i could spell the name
i was gonna be real quiet over here
because i'm an arsenal fan so
yeah thank you today yeah
i was just looking forward to watching
arsenal fan tv later i don't get to
watch it
i only watch it when they do really
badly yeah it's very funny
oh i was about to say i am dead last but
no i'm not i'm not gonna qualify by the
way i
i may also i also may not qualify look
at her stephen uh
steve and i were right here right here
getting our [ __ ] clothes i didn't i
didn't call
him i didn't i didn't
[Music]
i know i was like i would have been like
31st
how am i not qualified i'm burning it up
on crowns but i can't qualify in
doordash wait was i supposed to exit
that show
no that was round two [ __ ] i'm so sorry
steve i keep forgetting what round we're
in
that's all right fully straight up holy
straight put that one on me no that was
my fault
here we go much in my distress arsenal
apparently played very well today
that doesn't look how i expected it to
look what happens if i do this
no who am i following here that's just
my face
don't mind that one i'm trying to get my
my stream to to show up
like your stream but it is really not
happening it's just a big black box oh
my god
what we want never mind on that
are you are you 2086 steve i am yes okay
i'm watching you oh he's on a fruit
shoot i see i see i see
him oh my sorry you guys are trying he's
getting fruited
i'm sorry about it when watching sports
do you watch the whole thing or what
what does that mean odd clown
yeah you watch the whole you watch the
whole sport
alana is only level 23 get good
am i i mean i play this game oh wait for
what
i don't even know what you're referring
to is 23 does this game have levels
i don't know what's happening but i do
play this game on pc and playstation
pretty much split so i don't know
i don't know what's happening
[Music]
[Music]
braves uh name is racist though right
yeah probably
we're almost at 19k
if you want to donate to try to raise
money for fire relief that would be
a very cool huh how would i do that if i
wanted
there's a link in the description see if
i'm glad you watched it's tilted my
campaign i also tweeted it
you'd be super sexy if you donated to
this that would be that would be
hot i have no idea how late i'm planning
on playing tonight i'm going to play
until
i was going to play till 10. no there's
four guys left in me
all of the guys have fallen are you
going to drop at 10 um
elana yeah in that case i will let
felicia know
because if she if she wants it
to be uh i think big ben will do what he
always does throw a bunch of touch nails
get hurt and then our team will fall
apart
that's sort of excellent that sounds
promising
uh it's after the steelers every year we
banked our we kind of do what the
patriots did we're like building a team
around one dude except
our dude is made of fiberglass so
yeah that really throws a spanner in the
wax yeah yeah
huge bummer my game is all locked up
oh there it is it was frozen but then it
then it was okay
weird the fall guys situation it looks
like it was going to be bad but then it
was okay
there's still a lot of work to cool love
that for me good start great start
your fall guy's name kind of fell apart
nice
donate to virally
the vanguard here you know i'm doing
fine
i'm not scared of uh whatever this round
is this is well i don't [ __ ] know the
names
this is dizzy heights okay the one with
the spinny discs is dizzy heights
telling you man what are you telling
them are you are you talking about us
are you talking
about us no i'm just saying i'm just
saying like look if you
if you were a better and you're betting
on fall guys and you're like
oh andy on dizzying heights yeah i take
that any day and big
you know me too actually i feel pretty
good about disney heights
we're all gonna we're all gonna crawl
neat little line of us crawling out here
nice nice and i say so nice nice
need qual you're gonna you're gonna
cross that board money to the fire
relief for feet picks all right i'll
send you some feed picks
shane all right all right you know what
i learned today you're not allowed to
show your feet on twitch did you know
that
really i had no idea yeah i learned that
today why
anything that's anything that's
considered could be used as sexual
like it could give someone sexual
gratification but that's everything i
mean that's andy's face
yeah have you seen andy cortez yeah what
about all the people who are really into
shoulders
then yeah then yeah that's why i i've
thought about like
what would happen if i just even for one
night
uh twitch streamed wearing the same
thing at the same angle that bruce green
does
because man's always wearing a singlet
and his camera's
like yeah it's like pretty far zoomed
out i was like would i just immediately
get banned they really get the [ __ ] out
of you
i don't think it would last very long a
true story twitch would come that's
which staff member would come to your
chat
and check it out and see hmm
dress like bruce green make sure make
scarpino during our
uh i think it was our january sort of
like
comeback stream our annual sort of
stream um
we found out that he has a wiki feed
page he's a very high rating on
wikipedia does he and then he then
proceeded to show off his feet directly
to the camera
and a very drunk tim was like nick
you've got some good-looking feet
wow now i want to see nick scalpino's
feet
yeah he's got he's really hot and greg
miller has an awful wikifeed rating
bad feed on greg really i mean i
i've never looked at his feet but the
rating on there is really bad
i think james williams has a pretty good
rating thing i don't know
[Music]
yeah i also think feeder gross in
agreement hey don't you
yeah you know don't kick shame everyone
has their thing
uh speaking as a me uh
feet are useless and i don't know why we
have so get rid of them
if i had the option to i think i said
this to you the other night steve uh i
would just
cut my my feet off ankles down and
replace them with like
long full boots like shell i would do
that if i if that if that tech existed
for me to do i would do it
oh you mean like a robot cybernetic yeah
cause like i have really bad ankles and
my feet hurt all the time whatever just
[ __ ] cut that [ __ ] off
dude i have really bad ankles too but
i'm always breaking incomes on the
basketball court
yeah yeah getting dunks being good at
basketball and that's what happens
getting it left and right
yeah you know something i've never known
about you andy uh how do you feel about
yourself in basketball
yeah like what's yourself situation
where it comes to this
sketch i'm glad you asked i'm glad you
asked i'm pretty [ __ ] good at
basketball oh cool
oh yeah i've been i was waiting for one
minute i got stuck just behind a
pineapple and then tried to jump and i
couldn't move just because he was
standing in front of me
that was real [ __ ] fade away all day
i didn't know i did what
someone just donated two thousand five
hundred dollars steven insult oh my god
thank you so much steven enzler i know
that name
that's that's that's crazy [ __ ] that's
what oh my gosh thank you thank you
thank you let me see if they left
stevens are great i love them no well
only this one stephen
is there any chance of extra life this
year there's definitely not a chance of
an in-person exercise i imagine they'll
do an extra life
he didn't say anything thank you so much
stephen um i imagine they'll we'll do
one but i don't know
yeah i mean it wouldn't be in person
we'd just figure out where to go we
would just do like sections and time
stuff
out i think so oh joy
incredible two things i learned about
two things i learned tonight andy's
really good at basketball and always bet
andy and dizzy heights exactly guys yeah
yeah that's also learning
we all know you're all we all know uh
that's amazing
yeah grab a tail classic gary i got some
tailoring
if i was better at grabbing failed and
maybe andy wouldn't have dumped me so
yeah he did say that about you steven
you got to move on bro
no
oh [ __ ] andy that sucks oh [ __ ] andy
that's good oh no that sucks dude
uh you what did you call me [ __ ] oh
this is what's right for me
you little slurpy [ __ ] that is great
for me triceratops [ __ ]
sloppy [ __ ] that's what we call in this
game a tail grab
are you still into it
all right 30 seconds i i could see this
dude in the back boxing guy was just
waiting
he was doing the andy method i know it i
don't know
holy [ __ ] yeah i knew it the [ __ ] guy
got me
[ __ ] you and now now we're really long
time yeah this this is really bad
actually oh god this is terrible
ah this is bad i'm not gonna do it
you [ __ ] oh my goodness get off me you
stupid green flash
bean
things seem to be going well for gary
eliminated
i got grabbed by another bean that
didn't have a tail for no [ __ ]
ringtone
i was so clutch i i that was a very
loud squeal you gave out there gary so i
imagine it was bad oh
ver i was very displeased that's
pleasing
is this going to be last round yeah all
right andy all right let me get the dub
get the job that's all i need go check
this play out guys and i'm just
following
you who's left
all right come on andy i can't be the
only one to get crazy this one's got to
be nervous i've only ever won jump show
down once and i like it a lot i don't
know why i like it a lot
i'm probably like one for 20 on it
let's look at these bozos they don't
know [ __ ] they don't got you they're
that idiot
just dropped already off the yeah that's
convenient
i love to see it mint chocolate chip guy
there's a lot of robots around you this
is not great that's true
can't trust them no no they have no andy
cortez
i will murder you oh wow
it's like i'm there i feel like i'm
there do that
why did he take so long to jump i wanted
to jump to the other side
oh here
if it drops on the other side oh no
no i wouldn't let you do it
[ __ ] that yeah [ __ ] that bro that was
[ __ ]
everything went against you there
there's nothing they should never ever
single out one on another side
it's not everything it should be like
two and then the two break down
one just what i wanted
gary tell your [ __ ] friends that dude
what's that
tell your fall guys friends that what
this is what andy demands
but you don't ever have just one alone
on either side it's always like a two
and a two stitch
and then the two and twos break down on
one on one you know i mean sometimes
it do be like that though sometimes it
does sometimes
[ __ ] listen what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do if it be like that
and
you know man it's not looking good crown
wise tonight i'll be honest with you for
me like gary's getting all the crowns
for me i feel like
i don't know because i love people
there's a lot of crowns to go around
oh damn dude
see i'm not so bitter about it there's a
reason that me getting a crown got that
many retweets because
it's it's not a thing that happens every
day otherwise no one would care
so i'm good with losing i'm here for
free
yeah same bro i you know i got so many
triumphant wins that i just don't need
anymore
so like it's like whatever yeah i don't
want to take away the hype from everyone
enjoying all this i don't want to
previous ones we don't want to play
ocean wins huh yeah we don't want to
harsh their mellow is really what
yeah oh yeah yeah you know
there's these people you know
everybody's in chat when they see a
window like wow how triumphant was that
right like that was truly a triumphant
win
bro i know all my mommy say it wasn't my
favorite reaction to the
to the sweet thing that someone like
tweeted me they're like steve i don't
understand when you won
like you didn't get like twenty thousand
subs like tim the ticketman did i'm like
yeah i know about 20 000 subs for
winning
he got a lot of subs yeah wow
he actually broke out some world record
now the most subs at any one moment
in time on twitch wait so people would
just oh did they like promise that they
would for him or something no
they were just drawing them oh it built
it up into such a big deal
finally got it wow
it was all very performative by the end
to be quite honest oh my god i'm not
going to crawl
[ __ ] embarrassing i don't know man
i watched a lot of that stream and he
was getting
[ __ ] so hard by so many random people
that was round one right we're dropping
it
are we dropping yeah okay god damn it
sorry goodbye
i can't it doesn't let me do it
immediately no we we have to restart if
we want to be able to do it
yeah it is a bit annoying
a bit of a bomber
[Music]
someone in my chat told me to tell you
steve what did they say
um jesse caught that pass
jesse called that pass yeah that's what
i was told to tell you i don't know what
that means okay
i agree what does that mean
it's football football
i mean i mean i know football stephen
what are you talking about like talk to
you oh but atlanta doesn't so
yeah so it's illegal this is my stream
[ __ ]
i don't care less about it either wow
stephen and i have had to listen to
soccer talk all night guys no that's the
real football
come on
and by the way you're right
ready to go lost
the leader tied the lead
it's so funny too because i don't know
about you andy but for me
without fantasy football i find it much
harder to watch
every single game like if i'm in fantasy
i want to watch them all if i'm not it's
like well just my team i don't care
about the rest
i'm wondering which one affected the
other for me honestly steve because i
played fantasy football from
2007 until like 2015.
and i don't know if it was the fact that
my friend's dad had like the crazy good
nfl package and we would always watch
every game
or the fact like i think because i
stopped going to my friend's house all
the time
i think that's when i fell off of
fantasy football oh okay
and i just don't care anymore like i
have no
no desire to ever play fantasy football
again i
really like the thrill of the that red
zone like the red zone channel is my job
oh my god
red zone is cocaine dude it is it is a
drug
it is a drug it is
i don't know you guys know something uh
different uh
um the last season i played fantasy
football
it was the last season that peyton
manning was good so the season before he
retired
and the final game i lost by
i think three points and he threw three
picks
and like if he had like it just sucked
and i lost the super bowl there i was
like [ __ ] this game
no oh my gosh yeah
i i made myself yawn for a bit and i
have you on three times since
like i intentionally yawned the first
time and now i keep yawning
they're all around the [ __ ] field the
size of a
small town right [ __ ] i mean i just
want to
that'd be sick you guys talked about the
fake football six times we talked about
the real one twice so
yeah it's true yes it's true and you
guys talk like owners and stuff bro like
you guys it's like we need to bring out
like pep
oil money and [ __ ] on a high level yeah
it's because we're [ __ ] elite bro
that's right like at least when you talk
about it you gotta talk about it good
you know what i'm saying
so the person in my chat who keeps
asking how i feel about an asmr stream
like i'm fine with people doing those
but i personally
wouldn't just wouldn't enjoy doing that
like that i wouldn't have a fun time
you know i would i would get bored i
want to do something else
yeah i mean it's different straight to
different folks but i personally would
just get no enjoyment out of doing it
that's what i do dude i love these
tomorrow i live in here my cup of tea at
all
at night don't grab me [ __ ]
you let me go all as well i will say in
my in my
gary appreciation moment the one thing
i've liked about gary screams is he
watches content that i never would so it
gives me a good grilling scene to like i
would have never watched
russian slapping contests i didn't even
know that was a thing yeah aren't you
glad i introduced you to that what the
[ __ ] you watching over here gary
russian competitive face slapping
tournament what
like imagine big-ass dudes slap each
other
slapping each other in the face as hard
as they can
it's crazy it's it's remarkable i think
i might be into it yeah maybe i would
watch that yeah
remember like the wwe except it was real
that's that's what it is
the wwe isn't real yeah
oh it's real it's real good nice
well done i used to get tickets to any
like wwe match that would come to
australia because 2k would give them to
me
and i knew nothing about wrestling but
would always go um and my favorite thing
was
little kids talking aggressive [ __ ]
they'd be like yeah
get him john cena yeah he's a punk
this is so cute oh
remember like people dude oh my god
that's
crazy
but not really i was i was into the wwe
i guess
what the time is the wwe in the 90s yeah
i love that pando
anyone's interesting you might all
remember this but andy i know you will
they used to have this thing in the 90s
called the heart it was called the
hardcore championship the hardcore belt
yeah you have to defend it 24 7. like
everywhere
in the outside of the ring and like so
like all
if another wrestler or indeed anybody
could like pin you for a three count
anywhere any time any time any hour of
the day
yeah but it's scripted yeah
they had a referee whoever the hardcore
champion was had to have a referee
follow him around
all the time i mean that is [ __ ] up
really difficult hardcore champion but
he was like constantly always like
looking over his shoulder like super
[ __ ] bad did you accidentally like
lose the belt just by having sex
you're just doing a nice missionary and
then suddenly like that was three
seconds bro
i don't think i ever did that but yeah
they should have
there's a lot of money and i think
there's a lot of money in that storyline
that's a good industry that long right
anna you get it
that's all i last yeah three seconds
sorry feel lost it dude like the last
thing i
i don't know if it was i don't even know
if it was this year honestly but um
we went out to a wwe event we went out
to smackdown because xavier woods was in
town
and we we saw it at the the new
stadium that the warriors were supposed
to play at the new golden state uh
warriors place
and it's beautiful it's a brand new like
place and it's awesome and it's state of
the art
and now it's just like nobody can go in
there now yeah
that's a lot of money it's crazy it's
crazy man i hope xavier woods gets that
g4
g14 he's been uh campaigning for him it
would be good
i know because everything you know yeah
he's a good dude yeah
i uh i auditioned for them they asked me
to
and i was like i you know i wouldn't
leave my job for this and they were like
that's fine we'll take you anyway and i
was like
okay but i'm not gonna have time and
they're like doesn't matter please it
was like
okay
was really cool yeah it was fun i love
to fall in love around i did
are you on this jeep yeah everybody's
still in right
right right nope no i think we're still
here we're going
we're in morning let's go let's
so let me ask those who did love the 90s
uh because
we all have their star connections here
what what is a what is a 90s wrestler
that you would like to meet that you
haven't never mind
i don't know [ __ ] about wrestling i
can't help you that brother that i like
i would like to meet my channel
unfortunately a lot of them are
dead like yeah
and that sucks um not right i would
i would say uh shawn michaels probably
yeah
i would say like maybe machoke is like
emma champ chop is also a good
um like huge fan of the trio
so what about like 90s 2000 then we'll
make it easier
still i'm a champ let's see john cena
just say it alana you can't see him now
no
pokemon references okay i can't believe
you did that um
i would say uh sean michael just because
he was from he was from
like san antonio and it was so cool
someone in my chat said blaziken
that's a good yeah blaziken's a good one
yeah
what about the big the big beefy cat
look that probably exists it's in aurora
and cinderella oh yeah
incineroar yeah that big furry that big
dom
you know hell yeah yeah you're right
there gary
there's some grabbers yeah yeah you're
aware
grab his feet oh [ __ ] oh i was a little
too far to the front there
stress myself out oh god i got knocked
down oh god
get out of my way you idiots seriously
did you give up
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my
gosh oh [ __ ]
come on get
[Music]
uh this is gonna be my last round you
guys so if one of you could get a job
that would be
sick
okay great thank you i just like wanted
to like get a check in make sure that
you guys were still trying to
do that yeah so really heading for that
goal
good what about you mr winner
what about me what would you if you
could be the 90s 2000
wrestler that you have not met yet who
would it be
um i'm trying to think like who are my
favorites during that period
because i mean i i remember different
periods i remember like the really early
stuff like my my favorite guy used to be
and this is an earlier era
uh ted dibiase the million dollar man oh
million dollar man
a million dollar man um but i think he
was more of an 80s guy
um yeah i mean it's a boring answer but
i guess i would say the rock i mean he
he was absolutely was was the defining
wrestler of that generation
i i remember it's like an easy thing to
say now but i remember watching like the
rock in his early days like
even when he was a heel because remember
he was like at first oh yeah
i'm watching some of the stuff that he
would do backstage you know when he was
like you know
talking to [ __ ] uh mean gene oakland
or whatever and like talking crack i'm
like
the guy just had so much charisma i
remember thinking like this guy's going
to be a big fan
he was easily one of the best no one
[ __ ] talks mac like that guy
or exuded confidence like him you know
what i'm saying
yeah absolutely agree yeah it was like a
modern-day ali
in that regard he was he was very good
at what he did that's why he blew up
yeah every once in a while i just love i
love following the wwe
90s uh twitter account that's always
just putting out great videos and just
so nostalgic
don't they like exploit the [ __ ] out of
their workers and like they all have
injuries and they die early
and don't get paid enough and all of
them have horrible insurance yeah
there's no insurance a lot of them are
contractors and stuff
the game is glitching real bad from my
perspective of you steve
really yeah it's like you keep falling
through the ramp
oh i am i assure you i've fallen through
your five rings
this is uh close by the way yeah
um we're owning the zone though uh
you're owning a zone all right red
fields here
i'm going i'll i'll get it yellow don't
worry about it bro i'll get a big guy oh
i'm
i'm not pulling my weight right now i'm
not having a good spell here
i'll get this no no you guys will be all
right nice steve
nice i got a break i don't know we're
popping off gary what are you talking
about we're popping up
we're in first place andy and i are over
here
i'm not getting any rings i'm not
getting nothing i'm on
why is there a green guy playing i think
that's just the skin that he's using
yeah it's a it's a bug i think
yeah the same way that the pineapples
always show up white when they go on uh
i hate that all right i didn't know it
was a bug
well you wanted to win maybe we'll get
one there all right what
i feel like the odds of one of y'all
getting this is good
i mean 30 percent chance 30 chances
chance 100 percent will something to do
gonna be a [ __ ] chill
let's go we're all in the front this is
great
it doesn't matter stephen i could be 30
yards ahead of everybody
it wouldn't matter in this victory come
on gary
i got it that was not great not ideal
banana what's up with that one there's a
lot happening
this game's never over until it's over
ever oh
steve's [ __ ] ahead right now
what did you call me oh god come on
steve come on steve come on steve come
on steve oh my god steve this is looking
really good for you dude
steve steve steve you're gonna win this
if you grab it all you gotta do is
oh it's gonna be gary or steve
yeah the banana timed it so well
banana time bad company slightly better
yeah
just devastating i need i needed to get
you down for one more second
to see it oh my gosh and that was that
was very good
that was a damn good attempt by
everybody one of us
all there but yeah annie that was pretty
disappointing i think that we wouldn't
want to heat up your game a bit
i wasn't hit by everything possible i
got hit by a [ __ ] like
orange and there aren't even oranges in
the game
it came all the way from someone else's
saddle playing fruit shoot and he [ __ ]
you up
yeah god damn um well thank you guys
i'm going to head off i'm going to go
have my dinner that was fun i think i'm
going to watch
you guys can stay in my server if you
want i guess i don't go [ __ ] it in a
bucket
well i didn't say anything about that
but you stay in the stuff yeah that's
chill those are some words yeah
all right goodbye
yes what did what was your final total
for the i'm sorry what were you doing
again i forgot yeah so i've been raising
money for the american red cross
uh disaster relief to help with the
fires uh across the west coast of the us
right now we raised twenty one thousand
seven hundred dollars which is
crazy yeah thank you all so much the
link will be active for the next week so
you can keep donating
even when the stream's not here thank
you guys for joining me
thanks a lot goodbye everybody bye
and goodbye to you to stream thank you
for hanging out
i'll leave it up i will leave the stream
up if you guys i don't know why that
would be helpful for you when you're
here at the end but now you know
so you've been informed
you're welcome